when i said oh this rap is like ziti
you know what i mean you now ziti look
azity's pretty to me when it's freshly
baked and mozzarella stretching off the
noodles and all that it's rap
you can say whatever you want to say in
your rat but the people get what i'm
talking about
[Music]
when it comes to weaving food references
into rhymes no one does it better than
wountain cleanse ghost face killer
today one of rap's most food obsessed
mcs is coming to my backyard so i can
serve him a custom pie fit for a hip-hop
legend
and i'm going up against one of my
toughest challenges yet
iron chef america champion justin
sutherland
on his true tv series fast foodies
justin reimagines celebrities favorite
comfort dishes every week so i know he's
going to come with something crazy today
whose pizza will get the coveted ghost
face co-sign let's find out
justin welcome to peace awards nicole
thank you so much for having me this is
this is amazing well i'm so happy you're
here that's what you got going on i'm
gonna make a little pizza you know i i
heard we're having ghost face here i
mean wu-tang was such an influential
group i mean they changed hip-hop they
changed new york i mean they are just
icons and everything from music to
fashion to style i mean i'm excited i'm
excited so as a die-hard wu-tang fan i
mean i got i got a tattoo i got my
killer bj's on
uh so i'm gonna do a little pizza i call
enter the 36 chamber in uh oh he named
it he named it yeah yeah let's go you
know i love that you know they love the
chinese culture so it's gonna be a
little chinese five-spice chicken pizza
with a lot of fresh asian ingredients
okay so what's step one all right to
start here um we've got our sauce base
uh you know that i've taken a little
hoisin sauce some
rice wine vinegar some soy sauce ginger
chilies cooked all that down and that's
going to be our sauce space for this
pizza justin i have to tell you not only
are you going to please ghost face but
this flavor palette is right up my alley
all right so we've got our asian
inspired sauce down
after that i made a turkey sausage we've
got some garlic some ginger some
scallions a little bit more soy on there
good ingredients yes and we know ghost
face doesn't do pork so i you know i
wanted to lean into this uh this turkey
and this chicken for him marinated some
chicken thighs and some chinese five
spice
then i'm just gonna hit it with a little
scallions that we're gonna want to kind
of roast and caramelize in that pizza
oven yeah that's gonna be great and then
nicole just some shredded mozzarella um
you know i don't want a whole lot of
cheese on this this is really just to
hold those ingredients down it's not an
overly cheesy pizza one thing i am
really really excited about is is this
uni pizza oven i mean it gives anybody
at home the ability to make restaurant
quality pizzas in their backyard i'm not
gonna lie i got my dad one of these he
has made pizza every single day in his
backyard since he got it um so i mean
this is this is incredible i mean this
is the top oven period right no one can
mess with the onions i can't mess with
the onions
all right well let's have the uni mess
with this pizza and get it in there
and wow i mean in literally two minutes
this thing's ready this thing is ready
to come out it's looking good look at
that
look at that
it's all nice and hot and bubbly if
you've got some spice on there so we're
gonna hit it with some nice fresh
veggies and fresh ingredients on top
carrot mm-hmm
we're gonna do a little fresh cucumber
on there it's gonna help love it kind of
cool this off a bit got some kimchi
i've never heard nobody i love i mean i
love
kimchi and i'm on pizza i mean that's
game over little fresno chili just for a
little bit of acidity i'm gonna hit it
with a little fresh orange zest
chili crisp goes on everything for me
and then just to finally cool it off a
little bit we're gonna give it a little
bit of qp mayo wow that
is how you enter the 36 chamber
i love it
that is wonderful all right
i want my slice absolutely let's go
cheers ready cheers pizza cheers
i want to make sure i get a little bit
of everything
that'll work
this couldn't be more well balanced i
love the spices i love the when i first
tasted it it had a little hint of sweet
but then it just changed a little heat
you know and then it went back to like a
little coolness so i'm sure that this is
going to be a winter pie for ghost face
i'm not going to lie i think we kind of
did it
i think so
[Music]
justin your pizza was amazing
i'm going to show you what i have going
on over here so when i heard that ghost
face doesn't eat beef he doesn't eat
pork he doesn't eat scavengers i was
like
what am i gonna make for this dude so i
was like you know he has that song fish
i was like i gotta make something with
fish
so today i'm making a sweet chili jerk
salmon pizza first i'm gonna quickly in
this wonderful 800 degree oven cook my
salmon
so you're actually cooking the salmon in
the pizza oven yeah so it's not just a
pizza oven
that's crazy we can roast we can do
whatever we want wow so i'm going to
take advantage of that so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take my homemade
jerk sauce here
i'm just going to dab some on i'm going
to put this in the oven and let this
cook this is going to cook so fast right
you want to make sure that you keep an
eye on it okay so one more thing goes in
the oven okay i'm gonna grill up some
mango that sounds amazing so after i
grill this i'm gonna chop it up and add
it to the pie so now we're gonna just
dress this like an ordinary pizza okay
we're gonna take some cheese
i got my old reliable grande here now
i'm just going to take some mango
put it on my pizza
you know jerk and red peppers i know you
know this wearing yellow bell peppers it
goes so well together also getting
colorful like you right i see it you
know no i'm nervous we gotta do this for
a while right
we're doing this for the whoa you know
what i'm saying i think we're ready to
go enough and you ready i am so ready
all right let's go
[Music]
how do you like that it's incredible and
your crust is like perfect oh thank you
i hope so let's see poop is in the
eating right right well i'm ready to eat
now we're going to take the salmon
i'm going to drop it on here piece by
piece i love how charred that jerk got
on top too and then
what we're gonna do is i have this
lovely um cabbage hair i have a sesame
dressing okay with a hint of mango in it
all right so we're gonna put a little
bit
of cabbage on here and that's it this is
fish for ghost face
hollow yes oh look at that structure
there
with everything you got on there
i got to do it that's some strong you
know i'm so heavy-handed right i had to
make a crust like this
well damn
[Music]
that's delicious you like it that was
absolutely delicious
all of those different sauces that you
have going on each compliment off each
other
you got spicy you've got sweet
you've got tangy i love the grilled
mango i mean that came out of that oven
this is
dang maybe i'm a little scared no don't
be scared i'll tell you it's all
subjective this is absolutely delicious
though thank you so much coming from you
that means everything so we made two
great pieces today but now it's time to
go to the judges table and we've got the
legendary
ghost face killer in the building every
time you say that i get more and more
excited i mean he talks so much about
food and his lyrics i think probably
more than any other member but he's also
very particular about what he likes
right so i think the fact we both taylor
made these pizzas specifically for ghost
face i mean that's amazing are you ready
i i mean i don't know if i was ever
ready to to cook for the woo but i am
i'm happy for the woo amazing yo yo
first we feast you stepped it up
what's up everybody this is ghost face
killer and i'm gonna eat some pizza
today
yeah we pizza was all the time
especially when i was little i used to
live somewhere in west bright you know
staten island
real young living in the projects my
mother used to order that pizza i don't
think i ever tasted another pizza like
the pizza she ordered i know the
difference in pizza so that's why i said
i'm funny with it like i don't care how
big the name is
it's like
you got to have that taste yeah a bad
slice of pizza
sometime um it could be on this it could
be in the sauce like i don't really like
sugary sauces and things like that and
then you you don't know there's cheeses
that's not good cheeses too you know
that's different that's if you're a
pizza hey you know it when i'm writing
my raps
you know it depends on where your mind
take you when i say oh this rap is like
ziti
you know what i mean you now ziti look
azity's pretty to me when it's freshly
baked and mozzarella stretching off the
noodles and all that you know me so
i did a lot of that's a lot of ziti a
lot of baked macaroni and cheeses and
turkey wings and
you know in my raps but it's rap
you can say whatever you want to say in
your rack but the people get what i'm
talking about
first pizza is out hey yes uh it looks
crazy but i'ma taste it i gotta taste it
okay here we go
this is it
[Music]
the dough is definitely thin enough for
my liking nice and soft you know you
just bend it real quick just
really nice it ain't too too too much
but with everything else on it i could
taste that infusion
on what he was going with it
and it was it was it was a different i
never taste nothing like it tastes like
a spring roll in my mouth a piece of
spring roll the
ground turkey definitely cooked the
chicken
i might have might have wanted it a
little bit more well done
because i'm a well done guy other than
that it was good
the second pizza is here
okay let's get it
[Music]
there's one right here
barbecue i could taste barbecue in there
the dough is a lot thicker
which a lot of
thicker dough
i prefer uh
the thinner crust
i could taste the jerk
the sweetness of the barbecue stuff like
that that really really barbecue takes
over everything in my mouth the salmon
is is good it's cooked the way it's
supposed to be cooked i love fish
certain kinds of fish i love kingfish i
love snapper i love orange ruffy that's
my favorite fish ever
too expensive that's why some of y'all
probably never heard of it but the
salmon was cooked it was salmon was was
good though it was good
this is it right here it's going down
right now it's the finals
i got two had two pizzas
i gotta choose one
and um
i'm ready to get it on right now
[Music]
girl's face thank you so much for being
here justin and i are so thrilled i'm
trying to tell you there's nothing you
could do wrong today
nothing you can do wrong today you are
like you have car block just
we are thrilled to have you here i mean
absolutely go so i mean i already told
you i mean i got the woo tattooed i got
my killer bees on my feet i mean this is
uh i mean to cook for you today is an
absolute honor a huge fan so i
appreciate you being here appreciate it
thank you
the love is
right back at you thank you thank you so
much so ghost we can't take it any
longer just tell us
what you think
both pizzas was great let's start with
this one first it's called the 36
chamber
that's the same i cool into the 36
chamber joint the crushing everything
was right i love thin crust pizza for me
it was just a little bit of the chicken
needed to be
more well done the soy sauce
was a little you know maybe was a little
bit a little bit too much but it was
good overall this one here thick crust
what hit me first with this one was the
uh
the barbecue
i could taste a lot of barbecue and i
don't like barbecue like not too much
like that though
so you know
it was cool had a lot going on
they both had a lot going on but um i
made my decision
you know
i'm gonna have to go to 36.
justin you won
thank you so much i have to tell you i
know i lost this challenge yes yes but
i'm still honored i'm still honored that
you're here no no i'm honored to be here
thank you for having me yes yo it's
great i've been having a great time
i love y'all y'all some good people you
know what i mean anytime anything you
need from the clan be right here on the
side
thank you
i appreciate it
it's love it's love
[Music]
[Music]
you